So let's look at those results.
On my laptop we had a maximum number of threads running of 2048 out of a maximum possible of 2048.
This means that as long as we have enough thread blocks to fill the machine,
enough thread blocks to run on all the SMs, then we should get 100% occupancy.
On the other hand, the Fermi GPUs that Amazon uses and that Udacity runs on were limited to
a maximum number of threads running at 1024 out of a maximum possible of 1536,
and this means that we're going to achieve at best 66% occupancy, okay,
so occupancy refers to the percentage of threads that are actually running versus the
number of threads that actually could be running.
There's a useful tool that's a spreadsheet in the CUDA tool kit installation called the CUDA Occupancy Calendar
that let's you just plug in your numbers and see how your kernels are going to perform in terms of occupancy
on all the various GPU's that have existed over time.